bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est leur
devoir de moore hebdo 45 minutes pour
faire le tour de l'actualité politique
et parlementaire avec mario lefebvre
bonjour mario mois jean miquel et dans
l'actualité cette semaine les journées
parlementaires à rendez vous
traditionnel pour la rentrée au ps le
ras-le-bol fiscale et les doutes sur la
ligne politique ont dominé à l'ump jean
françois copé appelle ses troupes à
l'ordre des écologistes eux vivaient une
nouvelle crise avec le départ de
l'emblématique noël mamère et ça chauffe
au gouvernement à propos du dossier des
roms cécile duflot a violemment critiqué
manuel valls il met en danger le pacte
républicain at-elle déclaré la ministre
du logement demande au président de la
république de trancher
enfin une nouvelle rubrique s'adorent
cette rentrée le plus de l'hebdo la
semaine dernière sortait le jeu vidéo
gta 5 en passe de devenir le produit
culturel le plus vendu de l'année
les sénateurs proposent de taxer ces
jeux vidéo
c'est à découvrir à la fin de cette
émission est notre invité cette semaine
bruno le roux bonjourbonjour député
socialiste de seine-saint-denis et
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
nous allons bien sûr décoder avec vous
l'actualité de la semaine une semaine
marquée par des journées parlementaires
et notamment lundi et mardi les députés
et les sénateurs socialistes étaient
réunis à bordeaux
et dans tous les esprits les débats sur
la fiscalité et le pouvoir d'achat après
la fronde de certains parlementaires
socialistes jean marc ayrault à
justifier les choix du gouvernement il
fallait clore la séquence pour se
concentrer sur les municipales un sujet
de chloé buffard pas de place pour le
doute devant des parlementaires inquiet
de la montée du ras-le-bol fiscale jean
marc guiraud persiste et signe
oui j'assume d'avoir été obligé
d'augmenter les impôts
n'allons pas sur le terrain de la droite
et de l'extrême droite nos adversaires
parce que la question c'est à quoi sert
l'impôt et est-ce que l'impôt est juste
et bien oui
nous ne revendiquons pas d'augmenter
d'augmenter toujours les impôts mais
nous revendiquons le fait que notre
mission c'est d'utiliser l'impôt pour
des priorités depuis plusieurs semaines
certains députés réclament un débat sur
la fiscalité peut pas fermer la porte
avant même que la discussion ait lieu
avant même que le débat budgétaire ait
eu lieu
des amendements ils seront discutées à
l'assemblée quand bien même ça ne plaît
pas aux prémices il faut pouvoir en
discuter ça me semble la moindre des
choses
à la tribune claude bartolone dresse un
bilan sévère de la rentrée des
socialistes et appelle à la mobilisation
en vue des municipales
je vous le dit la gestionnaire et du ça
suffit depuis un an
collectivement nous donnons trop souvent
le sentiment d'administrer des choses
quand il faut gouverner des femmes et
des hommes
une critique qui s'adresse notamment à
jean marc ayrault le président de
l'assemblée nationale veut ton finir
avec le débat sur la fiscalité pour se
concentrer sur les municipales bonhoure
ou claude bartolone dit les vérités il
est allé trop loin ou au contraire c'est
juste et fondée
je ne suis pas loin de la gestione fois
depuis un an je suis dans le
redressement du pays et dans l'inversion
de la courbe du chômage effet la
gestionnaire mais ya pas de gestion' y
aller à tort alors que barcelone va en
tout cas je l'expression m'a semblé être
une expression des meetings nous avions
voulu un meeting le mardi matin c'était
une épreuve que expression meeting mais
je ne vois pas derrière cela la réalité
la gestione ça serait de ne pas faire de
choix depuis un an
or nous faisons des choix depuis un an
des choix clairs de réorientation sur
l'emploi si ça bouge aujourd'hui sur
l'emploi
c'est bien parce que nous avons mis en
place des dispositifs alors bien entendu
les choix sur l'emploi les choix sur
l'éducation les choix sur la sécurité
avec le redressement du pays
eh bien ça a été un effort demandé à la
gestionnaire c'est au jour le jour et
qu'il n'y a pas finalement de ligne
directrice est une pâle de zig zag non
c'est et c'est bien souvent dans les
commentaires que l'on est au jour le
jour moi je suis intervenu à aux
journées parlementaires pour dire mais
depuis un an nous sommes mobilisés sur
l'emploi ne pensons pas que la chose et
gagner ce n'est pas parce qu il y a eu
quelques bons chiffres ce n'est pas
parce qu'il y en a eu encore cinq
semaines que pour autant nous devons
abandonner ce qu'est la priorité est
donc essayons de ne pas surfer chaque
jour sur un nouveau thème au risque de
ces vrais d'incarner un zigzag dans
notre action est donc mobilisons-nous
sur l'essentiel l'essentiel pour les
français ça reste l'emploi aujourd'hui
écoutez moi je ne veux pas être dans les
petites phrases des uns et des autres
là on a l'habitude de faire des meetings
avec l'aude on en fait tous les
week-ends bon moi à bordeaux en tout cas
moi j'ai essayé de dire aux députés ce
que je pensais être juste dans ce que
nous faisions et dans ce que nous
devions incarner et j'ai dit aux députés
un peu plus de constance
un peu moins de jeu perso un peu plus
d'imagés j'aimerais bien que les
socialistes soient les premiers soutiens
de l'action du gouvernement tire avec le
partage du sol on a l'impression que
vous avez du mal à tenir vos troupes
en tout cas je ne le fais pas par
autoritarisme je ne veux pas les tenir
sans qu'il n'y ait aucun débat il y
avait 200 il y à 2 192 députés une
partie étaient là aux journées
parlementaires
presque 200 députés socialistes qui
étaient là il y en a 3 j'en ai compté
qui plutôt que de venir dans la salle de
séance
on était dans les couloirs pour discuter
avec vous et le problème c'est qu'on
retrouve ces trois là et non pas les 197
autres dans les reportages c'est une
façon aussi
mais toutes ces petites phrases ils ne
nuisent pas aux débats ça dépend de
quelques petites phrases ou par les six
et des petites phrases pour dire comme
je le entendu tout à l'heure il va
falloir débattre dans le budget pour
essayer de regarder ce qui peut être
amélioré ce qui peut être bouger mais
c'est tout le rôle des parlementaires
même s'ils sont socialistes nous ne
sommes pas là pour recevoir ni un
catéchisme laïque ni même budgétaire du
gouvernement s'en aille
voire à l'évaluer et à le regarder donc
oui bien entendu
et depuis plusieurs jours par exemple je
prends un exemple nous disons qu alors
qu'il ya une priorité à l'emploi
c'est une mauvaise idée que de raboter
un avantage pour les familles qui est un
avantage fiscal pour les enfants
scolarisés
le gouvernement a entendu est venu nous
dire aux journées parlementaires très
bien on a bien entendu les
parlementaires on va en rediscuter et
c'est en bonne voie et bien voilà c'est
un travail qui doit être violée ce que
sur plus de dix ans oui - de petite ride
la liberté est moins pratique phrase
très bien renault où on va parler d'un
autre parti va parler de l'ump pour ces
journées parlementaires l'ump a choisi
l'assemblée nationale pas de déplacement
province dans les sous sols de
l'assemblée donc ils ont voulu jouer le
sérieux et l'unité ecoutez jean françois
copé rien a rendu plus services et notre
famille politique quand la semaine
dernière nous avons décidé ensemble de
dire pas d'alliance avec les extrêmes
très bien pas d'alliance d'appels non
plus à voter pour la gauche alliée avec
l'extrême gauche c'est une évidence mais
en revanche pas de langue de bois pas
d'eau tiède on parle des sujets qui
intéressent les français et parmi les
sujets qui intéressaient les français
visiblement jean françois copé a décidé
de beaucoup parlé de la fiscalité
ils sont en train quelque part de se
refaire une petite santé sur votre dos
il a raison de parler de la fiscalité
jean françois copé parce que si nous
sommes obligés aujourd'hui d'avoir des
augmentations d'impôts bien moindre
d'ailleurs que celle qui avait été
décidée par les précédents gouvernements
que ce soit dans la tva telle qu'elle
avait été voté que nous avons annulé ou
dans les hausses d'impôts qui ont pesé
sur les particuliers et notamment les
plus modestes ces cinq dernières années
mais en même temps si nous sommes
obligés aujourd'hui d'avoir dans le même
moment la baisse de la dépense publique
et l'augmentation des recettes fiscales
dans une période de crise c'est bien
parce que vous connaissez je peux pas
vous l'a rappelé la situation du pays en
matière d'endettement en matière de
déficit donc il a raison sur plusieurs
fois oui que vous ce que vous disiez ce
une réalité héritage mais bien entendu
mais l'héritage c'est quelque chose qui
est aujourd'hui validé qui ne prêtent
pas contestation on ne dit pas qu'il
n'existe pas il existe et moi je ne veux
pas y faire référence tout le temps si
ce n'est de dire que c'est la situation
du pays qui est celle laissée par
monsieur copé qui nous conduit
aujourd'hui
car des ajustements et nous les faisons
avec mesure pour ce qui concerne les
français et notamment sur le domaine de
la fiscalité et avec justice dans ce que
nous avons mis à contribution ceux qui
ont été épargnés
ceux qui pendant dix ans avait exonéré
de l'impôt et qui aujourd'hui en paix à
nouveau et qui porte enfin un effort
qu'il ne portait plus avec la précédente
majorité
donc on l'a vu ce débat sur la fiscalité
mais c'est une petite phrase qui a
marqué ces journées parlementaires lors
d'une table ronde une déclaration a
suscité de vives réactions vous l'avez
entendu bruno le roux celle d'éric
doligé sénateur du loiret a écouté le
moi je dois vous dire que j'ai un
instinct meurtrier en ce moment je suis
comme la plupart des citoyens
moi je ne supporte plus hollande et sa
bande il faudrait qu'on évite de se
tirer dessus entre nous et qu'on fasse
tout pour tirer plus tôt enfin moi j'ai
une liste de genre tu peux vous donner
sûr qu'il faut tirer il y en a une
quarantaine c'est tous ceux du
gouvernement donc cogner à mort et
oublier que vous avez des amis sur
lesquels tu es en retard n'a envie de
tirer au moins faisant une pause pendant
six mois
merci messieurs le g et bruno le roux
eric doligé assume et ne renie pas ses
propos est ce qu'il faut le sanctionner
je me demande s'il avait bu s'il avait
fumé s'ils avaient fait quelque chose
avant tout casser des propos qui en
dehors du fait qu'ils sont irrespectueux
sont des propos totalement imbécile dans
la bouche d'un élu imbéciles mais que
c'est irresponsable ces mêmes imbéciles
dans la bouche d'un élu pour ça que je
le demande plus rien il est incapable de
prendre la moindre mesure
et donc je dis simplement aux français
que d'instinct meurtrier à des alliances
qui sont des alliances avec l'extrême
droite il ya aujourd'hui une dérive du
camp républicain du camp de droite
républicaine qui est absolument inouïe
et contre laquelle il n'ya rien d'opérer
nos sommets du parti ni monsieur copé ni
monsieur fillon aujourd'hui ils sont en
situation de pouvoir faire en sorte de
dresser de dire qu'ils se dressent jeudi
qu'il n'y a plus de chefs je dis qu'il
ya peut-être aussi pour vous s'il n'y a
pas forcément d'opposition se renforce
dans tout le monde depuis un an vous
n'ai pas vu une seule fois d'opposition
sur le fond à l'assemblée nationale ils
sont dans le fait de nier
ceux qui l'ont fait auparavant et dans
le même temps sur des débats ou des
freins
ce comme celle ci qui dans le climat
actuel sont des phrases que l'on
n'accepterait pas de quelqu'un qui n'a
pas de mandat même et qui
s'exprimeraient comme ça la classe
politique se retrouverait la droite pour
condamner des propos comme cela et comme
c'est un sénateur si pour les uns une
écriture élections et notamment les
élections municipales l'air ça risque
d'être contre temps encore une fois mais
le camp contre camp s'il ya des idées ça
ne me gêne pas alors sur les phrases en
tout cas l'équipe phrase ben non moi je
ne veux pas je dis que ces propos sont
des propos qui sont condamnables et que
si l'ump refuse de les condamner c'est
son affaire
moi je redis qu'un élu un devoir
d'exemplarité et que ces petites phrases
sur les instincts meurtriers sur les
kalachnikovs qu'il faudrait faut tenir
contre le gouvernement sont totalement
irresponsables en démocratie donc
sanctionner eric doligé mais moi je
pense que la sanction doit venir de la
barrière qu'il faut mettre maintenant
entre cet élu absolument indigne et les
français les bons pour le reste je ne
demande plus rien monsieur copé il est
incapable d'avoir et d'incarner la
moindre valeur sur ces questions là
bruno le roux on va poursuivre avec les
écologistes à direction angers où ils se
réunissaient mercredi et jeudi
et c'est en pleine tourmente qu'europe
écologie ait les verts vers ces journées
parlementaires éviction de pascal durand
départ de noël mamère une nouvelle crise
et plusieurs visions du parti qui
s'affrontaient les parlementaires un
sujet de germain andrieu et pierre
lascars officiellement c'est une
première journée travail à huis clos
mais difficile voire impossible de
résister aux médias chacun ici a sa
version ses explications sur le départ
de noël mamère si noël est parti
semble-t-il c'est précisément parce
qu'il a senti qu au sein de la majorité
actuelle de la direction actuelle
et bien il y avait trop de mains mistre
de clientélisme il parle de clans par
exemple et il est vrai que c'est un
problème on a évidemment un peu avant le
congrès alors chacun donne de la voix
pour essayer de pousser son avantage
pour moi ce que je regrette c'est que de
fait là la conduire la grèce n'a pas
tellement pris avec noël donc sein du
groupe parlementaire c'est-à-dire que
pour la première fois on avait
et d habitude ça faisait longtemps qu'il
était député mais un peu isolé c'est une
difficulté dans l'histoire du parti
mais ça veut pas dire pour autant il
faut déserté déserté pour mieux dénoncer
le fonctionnement du parti de l'in
s'affrontent aujourd'hui
d'un côté la vision d'un parti museler
sous le contrôle total de cécile duflot
de l'autre une seule justification agir
enfin de l'intérieur il ya des gens qui
veulent porter l'idée qu'il vaudrait
mieux rester tout seul dans notre coin
et ne plus être dans le gouvernement ne
plus être dans la majorité ils peuvent
soumettre ça au débat
chacun voit bien que sur une série de
sujets si les écologistes n'étaient pas
là on n'en parle même pas et donc on
aurait encore moins de décision encore
moins de changements c'est évident
évident ou non la question ne sera pas
tranchée à angers demain mais à caen par
les adhérents fin novembre lors du
prochain congrès d'europe écologie les
verts voudront on va s'arrêter deux
petites secondes sur ce parti europe
ecologie les verts on va parler dans un
instant des bisbilles
mais d'abord quand même cette
information en l'état ils ne voteraient
pas le budget est ce que ce sont
toujours des alliés
europe ecologie les verts mais ce n'est
pas ce que j'ai entendu ces derniers
jours mais on va s'en passer dire car
les tailles ne voterait pas le budget
non et gens soient d'origine donc le nom
allait d'ailleurs françois de rugy jean
vincent placé et barbara pompe ils y
étaient présents en début de semaine à
nos journées parlementaires des
fontinettes ensemble avec le premier
ministre nous voulons afficher une
majorité qui étaient rassemblés autour
des textes et notamment de la
présentation du budget et j'ai pu voir
dans la façon dont nous avons discuté
que le budget tel qu'il est là ils ont
certainement comme les socialistes des
amendements mais que rien ne s'empêchait
et surtout pas après les annonces que le
président de la république avait dit à
angers quand il disait en l'état ne
voteront pas le budget nous voulons des
amendements nous voulons un vrai
parlement qui va à la bataille mais
qu'on arrivait je vous le redis
vous avez entendu la majorité qui veut
participer
je n'ai pas entendu et c'est pour ça que
je mets en doute le fait qu'il y ait
aujourd'hui chez eux au moment où nous
parlons de volonté de ne pas voter le
budget ce que les socialistes voteront
les amants
écologistes pour que les écologistes
votent le budget ensuite est ce qu'il ya
un accord mais ça dépend de quels sont
ces amendements
s'il ya je vais prendre un exemple
précis je vais prendre un exemple précis
ici il ya les amendements comme nous
pour faire en sorte qu' il y ait les
avantages pour les personnes les plus
modestes celles qui ont été le plus
touchés par la crise ne pourront très
certainement tomber d'accord
s'il ya un amendement pour faire en
sorte de hausser la fiscalité du diesel
par exemple nous ne voterons pas parce
que je pense que ce n'est pas le moment
aujourd'hui d'abord de rentrer dans
cette fiscalité écologique par une
augmentation des taxes sur le diesel et
surtout parce que dans un moment qui est
encore un moment de crise de tensions
internationales sur le baril du pétrole
je ne souhaite pas qu'il y est une
envolée des prix à la pompe qui
dépendent aussi pour partie d'une
fiscalité que nous aurions mis en place
donc voilà deux exemples l'un auquel
nous mais nous nous associerons s'il ya
des des amendements et l'autre sur
lequel nous dit rien n'aurait de faire
n'est pas au bras de fer
il me semble que la tractation
négociations comment vous appelez ça
mais la discussion normale et il me
semble que cette discussion pour être
très clair a beaucoup évolué ces dix
derniers jours et les propos de mes amis
écologistes que j'ai entendu ce sont des
propos de discussions et non plus des
propos d'ultimatum ça ne vous a pas
échappé mais quand vous voyez tout ce
qui se passe à europe ecologie les verts
noël mamère pascal durand ou savez moi
j'ai à ces difficultés quelquefois avec
le fonctionnement du parti socialiste
pour aller porter la vie sur ce qui
passe les alliés donc
moi je souhaite nous avons défendu les
textes portés par cécile duflot à
l'assemblée nationale il ya des
ministres écologistes gouvernement ils
font partie pleinement de la majorité
j'ai souhaité avoir un des vice
présidents du groupe qui soit consacrée
exclusivement aux relations avec nos
partenaires de la majorité qui sont
maintenant des relations de tous les
jours moi je souhaite être celui qui
aplanit les difficultés qu'il peut y
avoir entre nous et pas celui qui
ancrait la semaine on a l'impression que
vous avez donc tu et les écologistes
avec l'éviction de pascal durand jean
marc ayrault a priori à réclamer la tête
serait ce qu'à dieu c'est une jean marc
ayrault a dit ce qui lui semblait être
nécessaire à dire c'est à dire qu'on ne
pouvait pas fonctionner par ultimatum à
l'intérieur d'une majorité
ensuite les verrons des débats internes
va pas échappé qu'il ya un congrès qu'il
y a des textes qui doivent être
proposées que le signataire du texte
majoritaire c'est le prochain patron
bombe à pascal durand a indiqué en parts
est une affaire totalement interne aux
verts
il est vrai que j'ai trouvé que la façon
dont il avait posé le débat sur un
ultimatum au moment de la contribution
climat énergie ne l'avait pas aidé à la
bonne compréhension des enjeux qu'il
pouvait y avoir à ce moment-là bon bah
voilà les verts ont pris une décision
ils en sont seuls maîtres est seul juge
vous avez pu constater en tout cas que
les journées parlementaires d'europe
écologie été quelque peu agitée c'est
peut-être pour cela que cécile duflot a
contre attaqué une attaque en règle
contre manuel valls le ministre
d'intérieur à propos des roms il est
accusé tout simplement de mettre en
danger le pacte républicain en écoute
cécile duflot on ne peut pas considérer
et on ne peut pas dire que il y à des
catégories de population ou leur origine
justifierait qu'elle ne puisse pas
s'intégrer simplement par leur origine
et deuxièmement que leurs pratiques et
leurs modes de vie sont un dérangement
pour leurs voisins parce que quand on
dit ça
parce que quand on dit ça parce que
quand on dit ça on est au delà de ce qui
met en danger le pacte républicain est
donc ce rôle essentiel qui a été confiée
au président de la république de réparer
les blessures de notre pays
d'apaiser les tensions de lutter contre
la tentation de l'extrémisme et surtout
la tentation du renoncement
c'est un rôle essentiel c'est le pacte
de valeur qui a fondé cette majorité
elle va très très loin cécile duflot est
ce que vous acceptez ce qu'a dit la
ministre du logement était devant des
militants écologistes
et pourtant elle était encore ministre
elle est ministre quand elle s'exprime
et donc il doit y avoir une mesure moi
je ne veux pas laisser penser par le
moindre propos et je pense que c'est
s'il n'a pas intérêt à le laisser penser
que manuel valls le ministre de
l'intérieur on voit la responsabilité
qu'est importante qu'il y a dans un pays
qui connaît aujourd'hui une type de
tensions que l'on peut connaître qui
connaît la nécessité à lutter ici contre
les phénomènes de communautarisme qui
peuvent s'installer mais de l'autre côté
à protéger aussi les français je
n'accepterai à aucun moment qu'on puisse
douter du côté républicain
et plutôt deux fois qu il est 3 fois 2
qu'une de manuel valls combat autres
guillemets mais je soutiens manuel valls
e pour toute son action
je ne veux lui faire aucun procès sur la
question républicaine et dans le même
temps je lui dis est ce qu'il y avait
quelque chose de révolutionnaire à voir
kylie a aujourd'hui une population qui
au niveau européenne et chasser chasse
et de bulgarie chasse et de roumanie
chasser aussi d'autres pays d'europe qui
est sous l'emprise de réseaux de
banditisme de réseaux mafieux et qui vit
dans des conditions sanitaires des
conditions sociales absolument indigne
dont un certain nombre bien entendu ne
souhaite pas rester dans notre pays
est ce qu'il y a deux lignes au
gouvernement mais il y a une ligne le
premier ministre la liste du flou c'est
du prémunissent celle de manuel valls et
gazon mais il ya une circulaire qui est
signé par ces trois là et donc arrêtons
le débat politique l'action voire même
politicien il y a une ligne qui et c'est
bien pour ça que non manuel valls a dit
des choses sur lequel on a voulu ensuite
sortir une partie pour faire un procès
au républicanisme bien ce n'est pas
juste c'est un procès qu'intente cécile
duflot mais en tout cas c'est un procès
que l'on essaye de faire depuis
plusieurs jours à manuel valls
ce procès n'a aucune raison d'être et il
y a aujourd'hui une politique qui est
celle du gouvernement il n'y a pas de
politique menée par manuel valls par
cécile duflot ou par un ministre il y a
une politique que l'on retrouve dans une
circulaire sur les question des roms qui
est un peu plus compliquée que le
quelques débats qu'on veut avoir de
l'eure qui touche à l'europe qui touche
bien entendu à la capacité à voir des
programmes d'insertion de
sédentarisation mais qui touche aussi
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux qui
sont en france parce qu'ils ont été
chassés dans la capacité qu'ils ont à
vouloir partir et rejoindre leur pays
dans son sillage la question divise au
sein du groupe socialiste au sein du
gouvernement
arnaud montebourg s'est exprimé
également au nom de boer je viens de
l'entendre il y à quelques heures en
soutien de la position qui était celle
de manuel valls parce que tout comme moi
il ne peut pas imaginer le moindre
procès fait à ce qu'est à ce quelle
image de la république la façon dont
manuel valls en carne même les valeurs
de la république et donc arrêtons les
faux débat si c'est le procès en
stigmatisation d'une communauté qui elle
fait aujourd'hui il n'a été fait par
personne à l'intérieur de ce
gouvernement et n'appartient pas à notre
tradition donc regardons les problèmes
en face et on peut vouloir mesurer
l'exaspération de population de notre
pays confronté aujourd'hui à cette
question on peut mesurer les enjeux pour
la communauté rom
sans pour autant être dans des procès
d'intention que je peux les voir et puis
quelques temps cécile duflot un appel au
président de la république pour arbitrer
est-ce qu'il doit intervenir ou pas du
président de la république
il a aujourd'hui une politique qui est
menée par son gouvernement qui est
résumé dans une circulaire d'accord mais
cécile duflot dit c'est au président de
la république de se déterminer ma pensée
c'est moi ou lui mais je pense que les
ministres auraient bien tort et là
encore je disais tout à l'heure qu'on ne
fonctionne pas par ultimatum ni à
l'intérieur de la majorité ni envers les
femmes le président de la république et
donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas
d'ultimatum à avoir pour personne
surtout quand tout le monde connaît et
donc voilà les journées parlementaires
sont terminées on sort des meetings
c'est valable autant pour ceux qui
s'expriment devant les socialistes que
pour ceux qui s'expriment
devant les écologistes revenons à la
réalité et notre politique aujourd'hui
sur la question rom nous pouvons
clairement l'assumé parce qu'elle est
clairement défini dans une circulaire
qui est signée par tous ses ministres
mais justement bruxelles a également mis
en garde la france la commission
européenne par la voix de viviane reding
a menacé de sanctions oui la commission
nous dit mais elle ne le dis pas
simplement à la france elle lui dit il
ya des crédits qui sont consacrés à
l'insertion qu'il faut peut-être mettre
en oeuvre de façon plus forte si
difficile moi je suis confronté dans ma
circonscription aux portes de ma
circonscription je l'étais dans ma
circonscription sous les ponts
d'autoroutes assez constant qui sont
mécontents dans des conditions
absolument terrible je suis confronté
dans la relation avec les associations
et je vois bien qu'il ya aujourd'hui une
partie de ceux qui sont sous ses pompes
qui souhaiteraient avoir des conditions
bien entendu plus descendre sédentarisés
mais qu'il ya aussi une partie est bien
qu'ils n'entrent pas aujourd'hui ou qui
n'entre qu'à difficulté et donc il est
difficile de consacrer des programmes
aussi quand il n'ya pas quelquefois de
volonté quand il ya une emprise trop
forte des réseaux mafieux qui empêche
ceux qui sont là de se décider donc
j'accepte les critiques et en même temps
je ne les partage pas elles n'ont pas de
réalité aujourd'hui par rapport à ce que
la volonté du gouvernement bruno le roux
nous allons revenir aux journées
parlementaires cette fois le parti
communiste et le parti de gauche ils
sont partis prendre l'air de la bretagne
et plus particulièrement d'auray dans le
morbihan
le parti communiste et le parti de
gauche critique toujours critique
toujours le gouvernement écoute et
pierre laurent le patron des communistes
français
ce budget là nous ne le voterons pas
donc s'il est maintenu dans ses
principes fondamentaux
nous refuserons ce budget à l'arrivée
c'est clair on nous parle de pause
fiscale en vérité on est toujours dans
dans une une évolution qui fait
davantage contribuer les salariés les
retraités et qui continuent d politique
d'exonération de cotisations sociales et
des exonérations fiscales pour les pour
les entreprises vous l'avez entendu ils
ne veulent pas voter le budget est ce
que le divorce est consommé avec le
parti communiste nous aurons un débat
avec eux ce budget c'est celui qui va
être le budget de l'inversion des
chiffres du chômage en 2014 et donc
chacun doit prendre ses responsabilités
si l'on ne veut rien faire sur le front
de l'emploi il faut le dire si l'on ne
veut pas aider les entreprises
si l'on ne veut pas essayer de restaurer
leur compétitivité il faut l'assumer
aussi moi vous savez les discours qui
sont les discours sur il faut donner du
pouvoir d'achat mais en même temps faut
rien faire pour aider les entreprises il
a ses limites et donc moi j'assume les
deux j'assume aujourd'hui que pour
donner de l'emploi dans notre pays pour
faire en sorte de restaurer de la
croissance il faille aussi aller sur le
terrain des entreprises qu'il faille
aussi aller sur le terrain des pme qu'il
faille aussi n'ont pas faire des cadeaux
mais essayez date dans des perspectives
de réinvestissement pour elle de
retrouver des marges de retrouver des
leviers de croissance de pouvoir
exporter mieux et donc je ne fais pas
partie de ce discours qui serait haro
sur les patrons d'un côté avec des
socialistes qui leur donnerait tout est
dans le même temps comment on fait sur
le front de l'emploi
moi je suis pour qu'il y ait des
ampoules des emplois et des tentes il
n'y a pas de croissance et nous avons
fait ce qu'il fallait sur les contrats
de génération les emplois d'avenir les
réformes qui sont les réformes du marché
du travail
mais pour le reste dès que la croissance
revient il faut que nos entreprises
retrouvent de la capacité à embaucher et
donc moi j'assume les deux bouts de la
chaîne faire en sorte d'agir sur la
compétitivité des entreprises et lutter
contre le chômage et le budget 2014 le
fait que vous mettez le parti communiste
et le parti guet devant le fait accompli
c'est bien sûr on l'aimé pas devant le
fait accompli non en même temps le savez
il ne participe pas aujourd'hui la
majorité gouvernementale
ils sont sur un discours qui est un
discours bancal il faudrait arriver à
faire en sorte de donner aux salariés et
pour autant ne rien faire pour essayer
de créer les emplois pour essayer
d'aider à la création d'une école de
faire des alliances avec eux pour les
prochaines échéances pays bien entendu
sur les échéances locales nous sommes
localement dont beaucoup de majorité
ensemble avec d'ailleurs des électeurs
qui ne comprennent pas toujours les
pauses
yu nan il y aura les alliances bien
entendu au niveau local mais il ne vous
a pas échappé que sur le terrain
municipal il y aura des projets
municipaux nous nous retrouvons ensemble
je l'espère le plus largement mais là ce
qui est dit par pierre laurent
je suis désolé s'il ne vaut pas voté le
budget qui sera le budget de la lutte
contre le chômage et de l'inversion de
la courbe en 2014 c'est ce sera leur
responsabilité en a fini avec les
journées parlementaires on va passer
cette fois au budget le projet de loi de
finances était présenté mercredi en
conseil des ministres le gouvernement
vante un effort budgétaire historique un
effort sans précédent 15 milliards de
baisses de dépenses 3 milliards de
hausse d'impôts dont la fameuse taxe à
75 % des prélèvements obligatoires et
une dette qui atteignent des niveaux
sans précédent
un sujet de chloé buffard devant les
ministres devant les parlementaires
devant la presse pierre moscovici et
bernard cazeneuve ont répété un même
message des économies plutôt que des
hausses d'impôts
bercy annonce même une réduction sans
précédent des dépenses publiques à
hauteur de 15 milliards d'euros
samedi aussi donc dont l'équilibré est
modifiée puisque désormais c'est sur les
économies de dépenses publiques repose
l'effort de réduction des déficits que
nous poursuivons en réalité le
gouvernement freine seulement la
progression naturelle des dépenses
publiques pour cela les administrations
vont devoir se serrer la ceinture leur
budget baisse de 9 milliards d'euros
plus de 13 mille emplois vont être
supprimés dans la fonction publique ils
permettront de financer la création de
onze mille postes dans l'éducation la
justice et la police les dépenses
sociales vont diminuer de 6 milliards
d'euros avec notamment 3 milliards
d'économies pour l'assurance maladie
côté recettes plusieurs fonctions
supplémentaires sont prévus pour les
ménages la hausse de la tva
l'abaissement du quotient familial et la
suppression de certaines niches fiscales
en contrepartie bercy prévoit des
mesures en faveur du pouvoir d'achat
nous
dont 900 millions d'euros aux couches
populaires et aux couches moyennes à
travers à la fois l'art et à
l'indexation du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu qui avaient été gelés dans la
majorité précédente à travers une décote
a crû de 5% ce qui permettra de faire un
geste de pouvoir d'achat pour 7 millions
de foyers
pierre moscovici se rendra jeudi à
bruxelles pour défendre le projet de loi
de finances car pour la première fois
cette année la commission européenne
peut demander à un état de la zone euro
de revoir son budget s'il ne lui
convient pas alors c'est le zoom de plus
de l'hebdo avec un autre éditorialiste
économique jean louis gombeaud bonjour
jean louis bonjour vous avez face à vous
brunolerouge vous en prie c'est à vous
de débattre sur ce budget 2014
alors il ya quelques questions sur ce
budget 2014 on va parler jusqu'au mois
de décembre
ma première question est d'ordre
politique tout à l'heure vous disiez ne
sommes pas là pour recevoir un
catéchisme budgétaire or il se trouve en
fait de catéchistes que moscovici
monsieur moscovici a reçu hier la
bénédiction de la commission européenne
et c'est la première fois que la
commission européenne avant le débat
parlementaire donne son opinion positive
ou négative mais elle est positive sur
le budget que dont vous discutez les
parlementaires est ce que vous vous
sentez pas un peu humilié quelque part
un peu sorti de votre pouvoir législatif
sur la question fondamentale du budget
alors que ben vous êtes contraints de
simplement d'avaliser ce qu'à avaliser
la commission non justement si ça avait
été cela et je m'étais exprimé en ce
sens au moment où il y avait tous ces
débats sur la solidarité en europe pour
qu' on puisse organiser de la solidarité
en europe et notamment sur des questions
qui peuvent toucher ou à la
mutualisation des dettes par exemple
nous n'allons pas assez loin
je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait un corps
communs qu'ils puissent être demandé aux
pays de l'union européenne et donc il
faut accepter une capacité à être
regarder voire à être jugé mais ça c'est
je pense le corollaire pour pouvoir
continuer à voter et à décider moi je
leur dis souvent j'ai les débats avec la
commission européenne
non pas sur l'objectif que nous devons
poursuivre l'objectif qui est celui de
la commission open et ensuite celui qui
avait été donnée par le président de la
république dans la campagne
par contre je veux qu'on nous laisse
juge
moyen je veux qu'on nous laisse juges
des priorités je n'accepte pas que l'on
décide à notre place ce qui devrait être
bon pour la france ou pas mais qu'il y
est une analyse qu'on appelle un peu
macro économiques macro budgétaires de
bruxelles
je trouve aujourd'hui que cela fait
partie des règles du jeu que nous devons
accepter rien à partir de là quelle est
votre marge de manoeuvre en tant que
parlementaire sur cette affaire de
budgétaire mais ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur du budget tout simplement
faire la part entre ce qui doit être
les économies sur la dépense publique et
les recettes nouvelles nous sommes
clairement en 2014 sur une tendance où
nous voulons aller très largement vers
des économies sur la dépense publique ce
qui n'a jamais été fait ce qui n'est pas
facile d'ailleurs moi je vais demander
au ministre de venir s'expliquer parce
que j'ai des interrogations sur ces 15
milliards que nous avons de baisse de la
dépense publique sont la façon cela va
se situer je sais que ça ne sera pas
facile mais il nous reste dans
l'intérieur des choix à faire le choix
sur l'éducation n'avait pas été celui de
la précédente majorité nous le faisons
avec des moyens budgétaires lourd donc
il reste bien entendu un pouvoir puis
jetair mais un petit de la marge au sens
d'une teigne hot
non mais de la marge en terme de
discussions quand on est sur une nation
comme la france qui a quand même un
budget solide qui a des capacités de
ressources oui bien entendu il peut y
avoir des politiques qui incarnent des
idées différentes des projets différents
et il y a toujours une marge
on n'est pas dans la gestion need quand
on fait un budget on est lente la
politique
alors j'ai des interrogations sur le
ministre à propos de la dépense publique
moi j'ai une question est ce que vous
trouvez normal quand même de considérer
comme une économie
le fait que vous un versier la tendance
de la dépense à dire que vous dites si
on n'avait pas été là la toile et les
dépenses auraient augmenté de 6% avec
moi elles augmentent de 0 2%
donc le différentiel entre x 0 2 c'est
de l'économie est-ce que c'est pas un
peu de gymnastique statistiques ça ça
peut sembler lettre simplement il ya
deux éléments qui viennent contrer cela
d'abord l'évolution ces dernières années
simplement le fait de regarder il y a
une tendance à l'évolution des dépenses
publiques ces dernières années qui n'a
jamais été contré la deuxième chose
c'est que la dépense publique
elles augmentent de toute façon d'année
en année par un certain nombre de
kahnisme qui sont des mécanismes
d'augmentation ici notamment sur la
masse salariale et donc tendanciellement
elle augmente toujours
et donc là diminué d'abord en diminuer
l'augmentation est ensuite diminuer la
dépense publique parce que pour la
première fois ce budget ne va pas
simplement être un budget où l'on va
diminuer l'augmentation on va diminuer
la dépense publique sur le budget 2014
certes relative on peut un peu mais un
milliard et demi mais c'est déjà un
mouvement qui n'a jamais été connu
auparavant et un mouvement que nous
devons discuter c'est pour ça que je
veux en discuter parce que il faut
diminuer les dépenses publiques sans
pour autant perdre la qualité des
orientations qui sont les nôtres
notamment je le rappelle en matière
d'emplois et d'éducation justement la
dernière question justement si la
diminution de la dépense la diminution
du rythme de la dépense est une
diminution on en vient à une question de
fond quand vous parlais tout à l'heure
vous avez encore répété l'inversion de
la courbe du chômage
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là est
ce que vous entendez justement que le
chômage va augmenter de moins en moins
vite
ou bien est ce que vous entendez que le
nombre de chômeurs va diminuer parce que
si vous considérez que vous diminuer la
dépense en inversant la courbe de
l'augmentation est ce qu'est ce que
c'est qu'en tant dévoué ça jamais le
premier ministre l'a précisé où le
président de la république aussi qu
entendez-vous exactement par inversion
de la courbe du chômage
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage pour
moi c'est ne pas se réjouir uniquement
des chiffres qui ont été ceux du mois
d'août par exemple c'est bien pour ça
que sur la méthode je vais vous dire que
pour moi
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage
c'est une tendance durable qui vise à ce
qu'il y ait moins de chômeurs et pas
simplement une décélération dans la
courbe du chômage et je crois que le
président de la république est très
claire sur cette question en tout cas
quand on en parle avec lui il n'est pas
question de biaiser pour dire ça
augmenterait moins que l'inversion de la
courbe du chômage du nombre de c'est la
capacité à rentrer dans une baisse
continue du nombre de chômeurs dans
notre vie merci jean louis gombeaud pour
votre éclairage bruno le roux à
poursuivre notre tour de la semaine
jeudi françois hollande était à florange
c'était un déplacement à hauts risques
un an et demi après sa première visite
françois hollande est donc revenu à
florange sifflé par une centaine de
salariés déçus par les promesses non
tenues
face aux syndicats et aux salariés
justement le président a justifié ses
choix et il a annoncé la création d'un
centre de recherche écouter le président
aujourd'hui je suis venu faire une
annonce qui est celle de la création
d'une plate-forme public de recherche et
de développement industriel pour la
sidérurgie lorraine
cette plateforme n'est pas un centre de
recherche de plus c'est un centre de
recherche qui a vocation à avoir des
conséquences industrielles de prendre
tous les projets qui seront présentés
pour assurer l'acier de demain elle
bruno le roux les promesses seront elles
tenues cette fois elles ont été tenues
auparavant et moi je ne veux pas laisser
penser que les promesses n'auraient pas
été tenues
le président de la république avait dit
je reviendrai à florange il est revenu à
florange il avait dit il n'y aura pas de
licenciement à florange et ceux qui
veulent aujourd'hui entretenir cette
idée qu'il aurait promis qu'il n'y
aurait pas de fermeture des hauts
fourneaux dont on connaît les
difficultés dont on sait d'ailleurs
qu'ils étaient pour une partie en fin de
vie industrielle qu'il aurait fallu
faire des investissements très lourds
et bien cela ça ne faisait pas partie
des promesses il y avait les
investissements de monsieur mittal ils
sont en train d'être réalisé il y avait
une promesse faite aux salariés qu'il
n'y aurait pas de chômeurs et des
reconversions s'est réalisée aujourd'hui
et il y a aussi cet engagement qui est
maintenant pris par le président de la
république de faire de ce savoir faire
des ouvriers des salariés des ouvriers
spécialisés de l'encadrement de faire un
pôle d'excellence et ça a été salué à sa
juste mesure par tous ceux qui sont sur
le site trois ans pour transformer
florange il
c'est pas facile bien entendu mais ça
fait partie des territoires qui sont les
territoires durement touchés et sur
lequel il faut concentrer l'effort et
moi je dis mon profond respect pour ceux
qui travaillent aujourd'hui sur la
sidérurgie dans ces bassins qui sont des
bassins qui souffre et en même temps je
leur dis voyez il ya un président de la
république il n'est pas dans l'esbrouffe
ils devaient y retourner il y est
retourné il a fait des annonces précises
aussi chaque année ça va être un peu le
symbole du quinquennat sa roche de
solutré la roche de solutré ce quelque
chose d'autre que cela s'avère une autre
signification beaucoup plus mais là
c'est en terme d'engagement quelque
chose de fort un président de la
république qui dit malgré toutes les
critiques il ya pu y avoir
malgré le fait qu'on est travestie les
engagements qui avaient été les miens
pour certains je veux revenir je veux
l'air précisé tout simplement parce que
je dois le respect le respect à ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui dans cette situation
et l'on voit bien là que ceux qui
souffrent ceux qui aujourd'hui sont les
salariés les plus touchés sont quand
même les premiers aujourd'hui dans
l'esprit du président de la république
pour lesquelles il faut se mobiliser ou
non à l'euro on va prendre un petit peu
notre direction cette fois je voudrais
savoir si vous vous intéressez aux jeux
vidéo et si vous connaissez ce fameux j2
veut jeu vidéo qui est sorti il ya peu
de temps qui s'appelle gta sont les jeux
vidéo pour moi ça n'existe que par la
simulation et les fly simulateur ou les
choses comme ça que beaucoup qui sont
d'aller des jeux pacifique mais oh j'ai
entendu beaucoup parler du jeu dont nous
avons parlé alors on va s'y intéresser
tout de suite c'est le plus de l'hebdo
plus d'un million d'exemplaires vendus
gta5 c'est un peu la vie des gangsters
plus vrai que nature
alors les sénateurs au même moment
s'interroge sur cette économie virtuelle
et si on taxait les jeux vidéo reportage
une semaine après sa sortie le cinquième
opus du désormais célèbre jeu vidéo gta
s'est déjà écoulé à plus d'un million
d'exemplaires en france un record pour
le studio écossais rockstar north dans
un secteur qui dégage plus de chiffre
d'affaires que l'industrie du cinéma
la france a elle aussi une carte à jouer
il ya un très bon accueil à une bonne
formation il ya des gens créatifs
il ya des très bons programmeurs qui
monde entier vient de débaucher
il ya des bons graphistes démons
designers n'ont globalement bonne terre
pour la vidéo en termes de talent en
effet depuis quelques années beaucoup de
jeunes diplômés de développeur français
sont attirés par des structures situées
dans des pays fiscalement plus
avantageux on à montréal qui est venu
nous voir en nous disant on a de belles
aurores pour vous implantez on vous aide
dans votre implantation regard des
crédits d'impôt en plus on a des crédits
d'impôt aux salariés exploite sur leur
revenu personnel
évidemment c'est un calcul intéressant
une fuite des cerveaux prise au sérieux
par les pouvoirs publics
cette semaine le sénateur d'europe
écologie les verts andré gattolin et
l'ump bruno retailleau ont présenté leur
rapport intitulé jeux vidéo le texte
égrène une série de propositions
concernant la fiscalité et le soutien à
la production nationale
on souhaite aussi créer une petite ax
d'une dizaine de centimes sur tous les
jeux sur supports physiques qui sont
vendus sur territoire français 80% de
ces jeux viennent d'autres pays de pays
étrangers
et ça permettrait avec cette ressource
se crée de financer si j'ose dire le
cycle du jeu vidéo français
une mesure qui sera discuté au ministère
de la culture
parce que les jeux vidéo sont devenus
des produits culturels comme les autres
alors dans ce reportage de simon
barbarie avait deux choses déjà d'une
part la violence sur les jeux vidéo et
cette taxe premièrement sur la violence
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ces jeux
vidéo et notamment gta5 qui fait un
ravage dans tous les sens du terme
je ne le ferai pas voilà je vois bien le
sud c'est qu'à ce jeu pour autant je
continue toujours à m'interroger sur le
niveau de violence qu'il y annoncer je
t'aime en seine-saint-denis au fait
qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui jouent
aussi il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
jouent il ya beaucoup de comportements
qui peuvent se retrouver aussi à côté
sans que j'en fasse forcément la liaison
mais en même temps quand je vois toute
cette violence je me demande si c'est
une capacité à la contenir ou si c'est
une capacité
quelquefois la provoquer ça dépend
forcément des individus mais voilà jeu
en même temps je ne sous estime pas le
succès qu'à ce jeu aujourd'hui et je lis
tout ce que je peux lire pour en
connaître bien les raisons une nouvelle
taxe proposée par les sénateurs sur ces
jeux vidéo votre avis si c'est vu comme
cela vous comprendrez que je prenne mes
précautions et dans le même temps il
s'agit d'un rapport avec beaucoup
opposition celle ci bien entendu dans la
période actuelle et est mise en exergue
oui mais alors là si c'est quelque chose
moi je regarde les mesures qui vont être
l'usure au soutien de l'activité
aujourd'hui des studios français et je
le dis très clairement aucune taxe ne
doit être mis en place si elle ne fait
pas l'objet d'une concertation avec le
secteur
si c'est pour dynamiser le secteur j'y
suis voilà je peux l'entendre donc
maintenant c'est à la ministre de la
culture et au secteur de regarder toutes
les propositions du rapport et pas
simplement les mesures fiscales
merci bruno le au bout de nous avoir
apporté votre éclairage sur cette
semaine marquée par les journées
parlementaires entre autres merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve bien
évidemment la semaine prochaine bonne
semaine à tous